[Music]
what do you say to somebody when they
say can you dumb it down for me
uh i want to get your take out i'll give
you my take if you're interested
yeah i i really hate that phrase dumb
dude because i think that's what a
science communicator you're trying to do
is to not remove any of the
complexity of the of the topic or
whatever it's just that you're trying to
get it across
in a way that someone will understand
right like
you can take sort of like einstein's
theory relativity and you could
communicate between astrophysicists and
being like here's what it means just by
giving them an equation and like someone
would understand that because that's a
language they're used to right it's the
language of maths and
tenses and vectors and all that kind of
stuff you learn and if you do a degree
in physics
but if you come across like you know joj
in public on the street you're not gonna
like give them an equation but
you're not dumbing it down by expressing
that
in different words at the same time
right and so that's what i try and do is
is still
keep the level of complexity and like if
you if you if i need i'll i'll build it
up with with
you know the concepts you need
underlying that but again in like the
simplest way i can
and i've always in the back of my mind
i've always got my mum right my mom
is like you know she she did high school
three phds in
astrophysics and she's a relativistic
particle
no so she did high school and then and
then left it sort of 16 which is the ag
can leap high school in the uk
and um and and that was it but she's
always been like interested
and intelligent but never educated right
because there's a difference between
intelligence and
and educated right and and and i think i
always think as long as my mum would
understand what i'm saying
[Music]
and i love the fact that you know for
those who who don't necessarily have the
night sky that they can enjoy
or for those who who really do get so
captivated by these questions
and want to get involved themselves
citizen science is a way for them to do
that you know
okay necessarily sort of going out in
the garden observing with your telescope
every night trying to discover an
asteroid
because i think sometimes that is what
drives people that sort of desire to
discover
something but the idea that you know i
need help doing my phd
but there's so much data that
you know me and my colleagues that
physically isn't enough of us to go
through it all
and so you know the idea that 300 000
people around the world could help you
with your phd
is incredible
[Music]
and so i always you know sort of lord
citizen science whenever i can because
you know i've written papers where
there's me and maybe like eight
collaborators from oxford nottingham you
know
chicago minnesota you know wherever the
world sydney or something like that
and then 300 000 other people you know
and it's like this work would not be
possible because all of these people
went to a website
they saw an image of a galaxy and they
were asked is it spiral shaped or is it
round and blobbish which is such an easy
question you know because
image recognition is one of those things
we can do from like a toddler
right it's one of those things that we
learn as children and so
getting people involved in that kind of
science with the knowledge that you know
this science and this result and this
discovery you know wouldn't be possible
without them i think is incredible and i
there's a great story out the back of
one of the projects so one of the
projects was asking people to look
through um planet data and
uh the kepler space telescope data and
it was basically sort of like we're
looking at stars
and if the star's brightness dips there
might be a planet there
so can you record for us if the
brightness is dipping anywhere
and it was such a great project and so
many people got involved the idea that
you could discover
a planet you know around another star in
our milky way that was
obviously people absolutely loved that
and
there did end up being someone who had
discovered a planet that like computer
algorithms he missed in the data
and he was a guy from the northeast of
england retired guy
and the media descended on his house
right and we're like
why did you get involved in this like
incredible project like what was it was
it the discovery that like
drove you to to do this and he was like
well there's only so much gardening you
can do and there's just not a lot on
telly lately
just this retired guy and they're like
do you think you you've caught the bug
do you want to catch another one he's
like no probably not i'll probably do
something different
to know that what i was spending my time
doing was
useful to someone somewhere whether it
was you know classifying the shapes of
galaxies or
the shapes of craters on mars or
flagging where there are penguins and
images from antarctica
those huge raft of different cities and
science projects
and it's it's yeah it's a tool to get
people into it but it's also a tool to
let them be involved in science
themselves
when i finished my university undergrad
i was like
so lost of what to do right i loved
school
and i felt bereft when i left school
right and so when i got to university i
was like few four years at least now i
like this this
is fine and then the end of that four
years i was like bereft again not
knowing what to do because
i just love learning and that and just
these halls of learning i was like i
want to do this for the rest of my life
and i didn't realize at the time that
going into research meant you will still
be learning for the rest of your life
right because you're not necessarily
being taught it anymore you're the one
figuring out the answers you know no
one's telling you the answers anymore
you're
literally like writing the textbooks
it's not like solving harder homework
problems right
exactly it's problems that might not
have an answer i mean you didn't know if
you'd finally answer these questions
quenching questions
until you actually did it